bonsoir régis est ce que la mort du chef
du groupe etat islamique
mais un coup d'arrêt au mouvement
jazzist pas écouter ce qu'on peut
remarquer c'est qu'à chaque chaque
président américain a eu son succès avec
un chèque du péché djihadistes en
souvient en 2011 ce avait été d'abord
oussama ben laden qui avait été donc
éliminés par les navy seals
abbottabad au pakistan
sous la supervision de barack obama à
l'époque ensuite c était le chef de
l'état islamique le chef historique
aboubaker al baghdadi al bagdadi qui a
été éliminé pas très loin d'ailleurs de
l'endroit où s'est déroulée l'opération
américaine qui a conduit à la mort de
son successeur dans la province d'idlib
en syrie donc à chaque le président
américain je dirai
comment deux superviser et d'avoir un
succès néanmoins ce qu'on a remarqué
c'est que la mort d'oussama ben laden
n'a pas commis un arrêt à l'islamisme
radical ni al qaïda dans le monde la
mort d'un banal baghdadi même si elle a
représenté un symbole historique est
quand même une défaite majeure pour
l'état islamique n'a pas non plus mis un
terme aux activités aube il est fort à
parier que son successeur abou ibrahim
hachimi al qurashi qui était quelqu'un
d'assez peu connu quelqu'un qui étaient
eux donc un irakien aussi comme c'est
souvent le cas pour les dirigeants les
plus haut placés de l'état islamique et
bien il est fort à parier que l'état
islamique va s'en remettre en général
dans la mouvance islamique quand un chef
disparaît ça ne conduit pas à l'arrêt du
groupe au travers et alors quel est
l'état de la menace jihadiste
aujourd'hui dans la région dans la
région elle est réelle et importante ans
et qu il est comment des choix me a
attaqué une prison hasaka à sa cadence
dans la zone tenue par les kurdes au
nord de la syrie il ya eu quatre jours
de combats donc avec les forces kurdes
qui ont été qui sont venus à bout de
l'as des mutins de l'état islamique donc
à l'intérieur des prisonniers eux qui
étaient à l'intérieur de l'époque delà
de la prison au bout de quatre jours
donc cette activité qui visait
béret un certain nombre de prisonniers
de qui étaient incarcérés donc dans le
nord de la syrie et bien montrent que
l'état islamique est capable de faire
des raids et des opérations très
audacieuse son activité de guérilla
aussi dans la zone de labadie à shania
c'est à dire le désert qui va te prendre
ça à la frontière irakienne en syrie est
encore très active un l'état islamique
combat-là l'armée syrienne et ses alliés
elle combat également les ndf donc les
comment les les kurdes les forces kurdes
soutenu par les américains au nord de
l'euphrate et elle a encore énormément
d'activités et il ya même un regain
d'activité ces temps derniers dans ces
zones là l'une des chiens est également
très présent dans la zone de samarra
dans la province de samar a donc en
commet en irak donc des ch est loin
d'être terminé son idéologie aussi il
faut le rappeler un trailer
régulièrement des tentatives de commande
de passer à l'acte en occident
régulièrement des attaques au couteau
sont revendiqué ensuite par le
protagoniste au nom de dèche donc des ch
est toujours là toujours présente -
structure est évidemment plus affaibli
qui à une époque mais en tout cas le
groupe et représente toujours une menace
mondiale
nous sommes à vos trousses c'est ce qu'a
déclaré joe biden s'adressant aux
leaders de groupes terroristes dans le
monde quel est votre regard sur cette
déclaration
les américains évidemment honteux
comment un potentiel notamment de
surveillance des activités de jihadiste
qui leur permet aujourd'hui justement de
déceler et d'arriver à identifier ces
individus et de pouvoir mener ce type de
raid on a remarqué d'ailleurs que c'est
évidemment des frappes qui sont je peux
me comment conçu comme étant le plus
précis possible mais la résistance
opposée par le leader de 9 milliards a
conduit quand même à la mort de 13
femmes et dans les traits enfant qui
étaient dans cette maison avec la peau
monde dans laquelle avec laquelle il
s'est re suisse il est également donc
c'est toujours toujours très difficile
d'aller eux parce que ces jihadistes est
en tout cas une partie de deux de ces
individus sont dans des zones où il ya
des habitations
à comment de la population donc c'est
toujours difficile de commandes de mener
des raids de la part des commandes et
auprès des opérateurs américains et de
leurs alliés le renseignement en tout
cas a nettement progressé et il ya
toujours une pression quand bailon dit
effectivement que les américains sont
très actifs pour essayer d'éliminer les
d'identié a dit ils le sont il n'ya pas
d'ailleurs que des ch il y à oissel dink
l émanation d'al-qaïda dans la province
d'idlib qui est régulièrement visée par
des flammes frappes de l'armée
américaine et un petit peu partout dans
la région les américains sont capables
d'intervenir merci beaucoup pour votre
décryptage régis que ce migrant
portèrent rt france décryptage après la
mort l'annnonce de la mort l'annoncé par
washington de la mort du chef du groupe
etat islamique en syrie